hello guys i am kajal pariwal and you
are watching code nethacks
in today's video we are going to discuss
about the tools and frameworks of
machine learning this video is basically
for those who are looking forward
towards machine learning and for all the
beginners who want to enhance their
skills in machine learning
so if you like our content hit the like
button subscribe for more videos
and
press the bell icon for more
notifications so let's get started
you know um as you all know that
artificial intelligence and machine
learning has grown itself a lot in past
few years and machine learning is itself
very large that it covers a lot of
libraries a lot of tools and a lot of
frameworks and we cannot discuss them in
one shot
and that's why we are here to discuss
some important tools and frameworks
so okay now before jumping on to that
let us first
quickly revise what is machine learning
now what is machine learning
machine learning basically allows all
the software applications to learn from
the input data what is wrong and what
[Music]
so total number
five
tensorflow
now what is tensorflow tensor2 basically
a machine learning open source librarian
which is returning python c plus plus
and
now
we
[Music]
now tensorflow itself has two versions
that is one point two point zero which
is cpu based and two point zero point
zero with the gpu base now gpu based on
heavy software
use content one point two point zero and
in the implementation the image
[Music]
okay number three tierras now what
is a high-level neural networking api it
is returning python and it can work on
both cpu as well as gpu
now if you know general keras you prefer
to cancel
number
two
psychic
now what is psychic
the cycle is basically an open source
machine learning library but it supports
uh supervised and unsupervised learning
okay now if you don't know what is
supervising unsupervised learning
okay now what it does is it basically it
is used for model fitting it
is used for data processing and etc it
is built on numpy cybernet and microsoft
now what are these these are our python
libraries which we are going to learn in
upcoming videos okay this is our circuit
number one
gaming
now it stands for contents information
right now it is also an open cv library
which is used for data analytics
reporting and integration it is a gui
based workflow now gui stands for
graphically
[Music]
you can use it you just have to take
data from somewhere model it up and
deploy it
as the boss i know can you
thank you
you